that you're seeing in the end okay so if
this cut is
out yes his
weapon tip moves to the
end but I don't push it to the
end I'm simply displacing it his weapon
is here in space and two objects cannot
occupy the same space and that's what
makes it move okay and then then he does
the Uki he's trying to free his weapon
okay so I'll show you the two
differences as I come around here I'm
going to paint the picture I'm moving it
over there even if I touch his subba and
I move it over there this is
incorrect one two I moved it over there
you can see where my tip of my Joe is
over here
C this is not the center line so the
center line is here that I must protect
okay so yes it's deflected over there
but with the yin Yong application of my
hands and the spiral rotating cross all
the rotational torque that you want is
present for what you want okay so as I
go boom I come straight down straight
down the center line you see where my
Joe is here right at his spine right on
my spine
over different different wrong
line and when you're training the
embryonically remember this goes around
here straight
down doesn't go over this
way we continue the drill boom
right
[Music]
boom
on the bookend you're also doing that
spir rotating across so on his first
movement I don't stay
here watch his weapon
slowly it makes an arc ever so
slight keep
going rewind the
film so that I have to fill that
up so my first movement my weapon goes
this
way not waiting here and then he
goes I feel the in space first there it
Isom around he
goes boom maintain the
adhesion
boom bo stick
Bo stick Bo come on
D
okay